hi i'm ryan right and i'm jeff chang
welcome two reasons to see when we give
you reasons to see and not to see jeff
chang so 21 and over so let's hang out
chip chip jeff chang is turning 21 years
old and jeff james two friends not jeff
chang and also not jeff chang I've come
to surprise him take him out on the
night of his life for his 21st birthday
and chaos ensues plus they gotta get
jeff chang home by six a.m. for his big
interview with the [ __ ] doctor people
Ryan's consensus there are some funny
reasons to see 21 and over there are
some funny reasons to see 21 and over
yeah you know a lot of people are
bagging on this phone but I actually had
a good time watching it Jerry's
consensus jeff chang is the reason to
see this movie jeff chang is the reason
jeff chang jeff chang I'm right there
with you mass all the crappy reviews
going in and I was sitting there
watching it go and you know what I'm
just having a good time being here
reason to see number one the cast Jeff
Jeff J yeah that's what it's all about
you know this cast this cast is great I
thought they were fantastic in it you
know the script itself is not great it's
not there's nothing special about it the
directing something special but the
actors I felt you know you can feel a
lot of improv probably going on yet they
all had great chemistry even even the
Jewish guy and I don't know those name
that's what I just called matures cat
I'm having trouble remembering attending
Jeff check and the Jewish guy and the
girl they had good chemist every every
one of the actors they all worked well
together and they made it a lot of fun
day elevated the material yeah no I
believe their chemistry I believe that
they were friends you know the movie
lives and dies by the actors pretty much
solely almost because it's an amusing
premise and the premise is good enough
it's like I say it's it's a lot like the
hangover but you know what what they put
in that structure I enjoy
and so it's a lot like hangover and
superbad combined yeah oh yeah exactly
it's got that adventure mixed with you
know college comedy thing which which I
found to be a cool little little martini
and you know like a lot of people are
complaining about the way out they sort
of behave these people but I know plenty
of like 18 to 25 year olds and they
seemed authentic enough to what I've
seen in now you're probably not gonna be
swayed if that's how you react to these
things but even the [ __ ] guy I was
still like yeah you know I've had
friends like this guy like I could see
why someone hang out he's still fun the
way it's justified to of why they're
hanging out even they talk about it you
know your oldest friends the weirdest
nip like that you know they have the
history it it makes perfect sense
they're all a little bit of the outcasts
and so I don't get why everyone's
banging on it because there were a lot
of fun to hang out with yeah at the end
of the day it's it's a hangout movie
Alan you're hanging out with this cast
and they're great cast to hang out with
boom Jeff Jeff Jeff Chang Jeff Jenni
reason to see number two it's
entertaining yeah we've been saying this
whole time it's a funny movie it's not
like laugh-out-loud funny throughout so
that's what we're saying it's
entertaining because even if you're not
laughing I doubt you're gonna be really
bored throughout yes venture I was
always amused I was always having a good
time you know it's just a fun party
movie yeah it's a party movie it's about
two guys wanted to take their best
friend out for his 21st birthday yeah
every ball had ideas of what we should
do for our best friend's 21st birthday
and they never really lived up to the
hype yeah what we imagined in this film
takes it to a tight sure there's not a
lot of substance going on and it's got a
weird message about like [ __ ] your
career and just do what you wanted 21
well it was I kind of took it as also
like you know it's just you know Jeff
Chang has killed himself for a dream he
doesn't want like be yourself stand up
to the man and do what you want with you
life you know like but there is a lot of
talk about like cuz that these people
are at the thai like you know I I go
there all I convinced adulthood is gonna
suck so live it up while you're young
but even so like nothing
doesn't matter with this it's a party
movie and how's the party the party is a
lot of fun like you said it's not like
there's not a whole lot of subtext and
all that stuff but there is some cool
stuff to just sort of resonate about
friendship and how things change but
then they you know find a way to be you
know friends again it just works for me
like I like that subject matter kind of
so yeah one thing that's interesting
about this movie is a for college movie
there's a lot of male nudity by all the
leads which I just thought was
interesting is usually it's like your
boobs everywhere but it's mostly naked
dudes throughout the movie which I
thought was just a cool like and I don't
like a lot of these College types of
movies but I ended up really enjoying it
it's a good time reasons not to see it
it's where you're like I could totally
see at the same time even though I'm
saying like I don't get what everyone
else's problem is I still the same time
actually do you see why there are people
who might not laugh at it that's a
comedy and it's hard to win over
everybody when it comes to a comedy at
the age were at her part of the target
Democrat so for us to be like well it
satisfies us I think it did the job well
yeah but at the same time I could see
why if you're old or even younger he
might not find it that funny it's a lot
like the hangover sometimes it seems
like they rip the exact outline of a
hangover yeah and just put it in here
you know it's funny enough at an older
couple sat down right next to me when I
went to see this and they seem to be
really enjoying themselves so like you
said this is one of those movies where I
could totally see why you wouldn't like
it you brought me a list of complaints
i'm probably like yeah no totally seems
go on really long the editing is weird
you know sure whatever but i still
enjoyed myself he's not much depth all
they're doing is partying and having a
fun time but it's it's fun and it's
clever enough and it has enough
personality to or you know you'll have a
good time watching it and everyone's
comparing this to the hangover and the
hangover has a sense of danger going on
yeah this doesn't really have a big so
you don't really feel a big sense of
danger I mean there's a little sense of
urgency it yeah so you can it's weird
you can find a lot of flaws with this
film but all the flaws that people are
finding it's like that's not what
matters with this
oh yeah it's a little scrappy you know
fun flick and it's you know I never hold
a ticket price against a movie because i
saw this for sixteen dollars Wow but uh
you know what I still had a good time is
it worth sixteen dollars no probably not
cotto matinee or something but or if
your other friends on saturday night you
know whatever you'll still have a good
time it's it's it's it's a good time you
know alright guys you can go ahead and
tell us your reasons to see or not to
see 21 and over if you want to hear my
straight to the point review of 21 and
over go ahead and click on the link
below also if you want to see more
episodes of reasons to see more reviews
with both of us click here to see more
reasons to see show and if you want the
whole real rejects experience just jeff
chang this jeff chang button right here
right here means subscribe but it says
jeff chang interested okay this review
is brought to you by Jeff Jenni Jeff
Chang chef chein they never once calling
jeff jeffrey they jesu call him Jeffrey
Reginald chang at one point yeah I think
they're like reading his name off a
medical chart or something yes name is
either long or longer yeah Jeff said I
hope it catches on the jeff chang dude
jeff j totally Jenna fitting and I can
see why you might call something that's
a jeff chang after watching this movie
it is a jeff chang totally the other
things that happened were you're like
jeff j yeah dude teddy bear penis Jeff
that's a total joke j
you